Speaker 1: Hey, David, if Trump runs third
party, do you think he can win any states?
This is a really interesting question, because
I think the answer is maybe.
Yes.
I mean, listen, if you if you look at a variety
of different states and you poll Republicans
and you say how many of you would vote for
Trump if he ran?
Again, for the most part, Trump has more than
50 percent Republican support.
I think in every state I may be wrong.
There may be some state where Trump wouldn't
have 50 percent Republican support.
The math gets more complicated when you realize
that a Trump Republican nomination in twenty
four and a Trump third party run in twenty
twenty four would differently affect Republicans,
Independents and Democrats.
So let's take it one by one.
If Trump is the Republican nominee, I think
that that will motivate more Democrats to
vote against him than if Trump runs as an
independent, because Democrats will see Trump
as an independent as less of a threat than
Trump as a Republican.
OK, if Trump is the Republican nominee, I
think that independents will go more away
from Donald Trump, where if his Trump is,
whereas Trump if Trump is an independent or
third party candidate, it might actually attract
some independents who otherwise would have
said, no, no, no, this is not for me.
I'm gonna vote for the Democrat and then for
Republicans.
And this is where it gets really hard to predict.
If Trump is the Republican nominee in twenty
twenty four, I think he has almost all Republican
support.
Every poll is indicative of that.
But if Trump runs as an independent, about
60 percent of Republicans in a poll a couple
of months ago said they would follow Trump
to a third party or an independent status.
I don't know that I believe them.
I genuinely am unsure that they would actually
follow through with that.
So all of these are complicated scenarios.
Now, could Trump as a third party candidate
win some states?
Yeah, I think it's possible.
I think it's possible that he would.
But the real question is, what does it do
in terms of getting to 270?
And to me, it seems abundantly clear that
the math of a Trump third party run points
one way and one way only, which is a massive
Democratic victory in particular.
If because remember, scenario one is that
you've got a Democratic candidate which who
wins the normal blue states and then the Republican
nominee and third party, Trump split the red
states.
OK, that's that's one scenario.
But even without winning a single state, Donald
Trump as a third party candidate could absolutely
destroy the Republican Party.
Because if you think of all those states where
Trump won, but by half a point or Trump won
by one point or by three points or even four,
if Trump can pick up even 10, 15 percent support
from Republicans in some of those states,
they split the vote.
And you end up with a situation like a Democrat
having, you know, forty eight, but having
a plurality and the other fifty two percent
being divided by Trump and the Republican
nominee.
So personally, I might my view, as stated
earlier this week, is if Trump runs against
Biden in twenty four and Trump's the Republican
nominee, I think it's very bad for Joe Biden.
And I laid it out in detail earlier this week.
If Biden says I'm only going to be doing one
term vote, Kamala and Kamila is handed the
nomination, I think that's very bad for Kamala
Harris.
I think Trump likely does very well in that
scenario.
So in that sense, I want Trump to not be involved
at all.
But Trump as a third party candidate, a viable
one who could get, again, 10, 12, 15 percent
of the vote in some of these key states.
It gives the election to the Democratic candidate.
And I've seen no credible mathematical explanation
of why that is not the right assessment.
If you have one, I want to hear from you.
Is there any scenario where Trump getting
12 percent nationally as a third party candidate
doesn't?
Obviously.
Become just a windfall for the Democratic
candidate.
Let me know, I want to hear from you